[Musica]
siamo qui oggi per spiegare delle cose
bellissime che sono avvenute
recentemente nel segmento dello Yachting
il primo capitolo di questa storia Parte
l'anno scorso al Monaco Y quando
all'interno di un seminario organizzato
dalla water Revolution Foundation un
architetto già Camp
di quattro partecipazioni all'America SC
presentò una casistica alla stampa i
tecnici ai progettisti presenti dicendo
quale sarà la prossima ragione per far
comprare la prossima
nave nella platea dei partecipanti
c'erano alcuni degli Studi più
importanti del mondo gli architetti
produttori di elementi per
l'imbarcazione e ognuno di loro rispost
con quello di cui erano competenti e
fondamentalmente già in quella sede
prendendo tutto quello che veniva
dimostrato si poteva costruire qualcosa
ma dove nasce questo pensiero dove si
incomincia a capire che stava succedendo
qualcosa parto dalla mia storia che 3
anni fa mi porta a terminare una
consulenza e a cercare di R lanciarmi in
una parte del segmento nautico dove
sentivo provenire un'altra vibrazioni
era il periodo chiaramente di Stella
Rossa e io da Scusate di Luna Rossa e io
chiaramente da specialista della nautica
sono sempre stato
molto sensibile rispetto a questi trofei
quindi usci da un cantiere che produceva
barche di metallo e feci un progetto
cercai l'imprenditore che per me era più
vicino a quello che poteva scegliere il
progetto lo contattai da una porta
semichiusa che lasciò attraverso la sua
pagina LinkedIn ed incontrai
l'amministratore delegato del suo
cantiere arrivai lì bellissimo con un
progetto
strepitoso lo convinse che si vinceva
l'america's Cup e chiaramente si
diventava i campioni del mondo del
mercato della deriva da riporto
chiaramente questo amministratore
delegato non vide che tutto funzionava
esattamente come piaceva a me e non fu
nemmeno così completamente convinto di
quello che gli spiegavo e mi disse No
tra 53 e 57 volte dallo stress e della
tensione del momento avevo una pagina
con la copertina del progetto dove feci
53 o 57 tratti non ho trovato il foglio
senò ve lo portavo stasera comunque in
quel momento nacque un'altra cosa non
nacque quel progetto Però quella ricerca
fu buona per una testata americana
Forbes che decise
rimasticare di un certo tipo di prendere
in
considerazione l'ipotesi di farne un
articolo E venne fuori un'analisi
chiaramente intanto su una scelta di del
signor Bertelli di distribuire
gratuitamente i diritti televis della
competizione poi si parlava della
contaminazione aerospaziale nella
ricerca tecnologica dei Team
dell'America scap e un'analisi verticale
fortissima sui ritorni di investimento
dei Team fece un approfondimento senò
non pubblicavano l'articolo molto
profondo no e a un certo punto
l'articolo venne pubblicato e io non mi
Resi neanche conto di quello che avevo
fatto in quel momento però il risultato
vero l'ho avuto quest' inverno
quando in febbraio durante un evento
dello Yachting che si chiama design
festival che si svolge a Cortina da un
pezzo Paradossalmente mi sono accorto
che un designer olandese che si chiama
marnix extra presentò un progetto di
un'imbarcazione per la prima volta
completamente
autosostenibile senza propulsione
endotermica e senza generatori e si
chiamava Project zero vessel questa
barca era autosufficiente era pensata
come la navigazione per mare di un tempo
era pensata come le missioni spaziali
progetti nati per tornare progetti nati
per essere autosufficienti in tutto
quello che avevano a bordo per riuscire
a terminare la missione si era scoperto
che quello che veniva pensato nell'eros
spazio poteva diventare elemento di
ragionamento navale non solo chiaramente
quindi la barca produceva elettricità
dalle Vele è quella che avete visto
Nella presentazione Ok produceva
elettricità 1 vir 5 MW dal piano belico
perché noi son queste le potenze di cui
parliamo quando parliamo di navi
parliamo di Mew quando son grandi sopra
1le Gross tonage Magari il numero non vi
dice niente diventano terawatt Ok
immaginate quello che dovete creare e
gestire e far funzionare quindi avete il
vento avete le turbine interazione avete
i pannelli solari avete l'isolamento
avete le batterie agli ioni di Sali di
sodio non infiammabili No un altro
problema legato a questo tipo di
missione avete tutto quello che serve
per andare e per tornare per essere
autosufficienti Ma questa cosa
fondamentalmente non è nata lì è nata
veramente in ambiente spaziale se posso
suggerirvi un viaggio il Kennedy Space
Center di Cape Canaveral in
quell'occasione potrete vedere il museo
dove viene ringraziato l'atlantis per le
sue 140 missioni spaziali e dove accanto
potrete F L'esperienza di tutta la
tecnologia che è nata per conquistare lo
spazio che adesso si trova nella vostra
vita di tutti i giorni Questo è il vero
miracolo Ma l'inizio Dov'è comunque
L'inizio è nel
1992 quando per la prima volta un
consorzio che viene dall'Unione
Sovietica Red Star 92 e the Age of
Russia 2 uno da San Pietroburgo e uno da
Mosca producono la prima barca
dall'energia Space Center Casa Madre a
conos scenza di tutti in primis dello
sputnik e successivamente del Buran che
sarebbe niente meno che il modello
sovietico di Space Shuttle È da lì che
partiamo questa cosa poi la ritroviamo
con De Marchi conosciuti solamente nel
2013 quando il Golden Gate Y in club di
San Francisco con l'oracle Team presenta
la collaborazione con Boeing e al 2018
addirittura da dallo yotin club di New
York con America Magic viene fatta la
stessa cosa con Airbus se avete visto
l'ultima edizione dell'America scap la
36a c'era niente meno che ineos Steam
che collabora sia con l' aerospace sia
con la Formula 1 che tutto quanto possa
essere mai definito a livello di ricerca
aerospaziale avete visto le barche che
volavano 1 metro sopra il campo di
regata si va sul foil la regata è 1 m
sopra l'acqua e da lì torniamo Tanto per
cambiare posto allo Yo in club di
Stockholm ma sponsorizzato da Artemis
Technologies ok Questo per la 32A
America scap che recentemente ha
lanciato un progetto di un trasporto
passeggeri di 24 m su foil stessa cosa
si può andare per mare per 10 m con
pochissima energia sempre con 10 m di
barca ancora su foil adesso cosa è
successo recentemente è successo che
addirittura sempre in prossimità di
questo distretto è stata lanciata una
nave che produce idrogeno Quindi queste
barche questi progetti non sono soltanto
destinati a centri ricerca o volontà di
sviluppo tecnologico questa barca che di
cui sto parlando adesso in banchina con
la potenza della banchina non ancora con
la sua produce idrogeno che è la sua
terza fonte di energia che unitamente a
tutta la conoscenza che C che è stata
sviluppata recentemente legata all'uso
effettivo della Barca rende questa barca
indipendente da un punto di vista del
diporto
Quindi adesso se considerate quello che
abbiamo detto possiamo fare una lista no
se prendiamo la barca a vela
immaginatevi il sartiame che in trazione
produce energia il pannello solare il
vento la turbina in trazione l'idrogeno
come detto adesso una gestione
dell'energia l'isolamento anche fatto
con il sughero ci sono delle cose che
ancora ancora prima di oggi magari
esistevano ma non erano montati insieme
nello stesso progetto Quindi adesso
forse cercando di pensare alla domanda
con cui abbiamo aperto questa serata no
ci diciamo ci siamo Sì va fatto un'altra
piccola analisi che sarebbe il Premium
Price che Bill Gates
definisce in relazione a quello che sia
il reale costo per la decarbonizzazione
di qualunque cosa che utilizziamo no e
nella barca ha un costo In più ha un
costo di spazio perché una barca
chiaramente è un volume definito da un
registro navale che stabilisce appunto
Quali sono gli spazi disponibili per
qualunque cosa che si voglia fare però
ci siamo quindi tornando alla domanda di
prima è il momento di cambiare nave
pensandoci bene forse adesso abbiamo
tutti gli argomenti per farlo
[Applauso]
Grazie